yeah did you try Jessica off all the
time honestly it helped because that's
like my first go-to if I feel sad yeah
and if I just golf that's your first
go-to it's a nice little reason if I go
oh [__] I'm still sad
sometimes
[Music]
and
that's uh my uh very very royalty free
music so go for it go for it
[Music]
also royalty free and welcome back to
Hot Seat part two with him everybody
make some noise
[Applause]
thank you
all right where's the can we get the
dick pick up real quick no dude we're
gonna demonetize keep it right there
it's just more for inspiration I just
like to see it out the corner of my eye
so uh if you explain Nick why we have to
do a round two what would it be because
we only talked about Hannah and her
relationship with Joe so now this time
we get to do part two and talk more
about you as an individuals yeah you
spent all that time last time talk about
British [__] and then how I'm not gonna
say anything with less interruptions
from Joe's the intention but it started
in the wrong direction right yeah
we want to know more about Hannah
tell us about who you are as a person
right now I mean to start with a cold
one
we're your own
all right okay and you're trying to hook
yourself up are you trying to hook your
niece up with you with a Japanese guy
with a Japanese guy nice obviously how
would you how would you how would you
introduce her like how would you
describe her and summarize her well I'm
growing that good genetics
good breathing stuff
it's our family very fertile family
in the future
uh no medical issues no allergies that's
how you describe yourself if you're
trying to sell me to something let her
let her finish dude I'm already sold
he would be yeah good Britain stock
very fertile family very fertile they're
pretty fertile all right
let's warm it up a little bit okay
what's a guilty pleasure of yours
guilty pleasure mm-hmm
besides eating in bed
don't be started
pleasure I'm just probably when I first
started eating meat again I tell anybody
I felt really bad about it why'd you
feel like you needed to tell someone
because like so a lot of my friends were
also vegetarian or vegan I had two
friends that ran like a vegan podcast
whoa family members that are vegetarian
vegan yeah they're all doing it too it's
fine I don't know but I felt so guilty
and I would be saying to him like
because I was so worried about
officially um we went out one of my
friends came to LA and we went out for
dinner and she was like you went to a
steakhouse and didn't and didn't realize
it that steak I was like oh
[__]
no it's vegan speak yeah and then after
that it just all came out my mum
actually called me one time and was like
are you eating meat now because this has
been like a decade yeah no like no one
tell everyone when you became vegetarian
when I was like 11. see
what made you want to be vegetarian and
11. we were in school and they showed us
a video of an abattoir
that's like the executor of the animal
can't show that to Asians they'll just
go hmm that happens in Rosemead I know I
was traumatized and I went home and then
the whole class went vegetarian but I
was the only person that stuck to it
really wow wow damn you got the
commitment
also like everyone made me feel so bad
about it like my brother's made fun of
me so bad for it that just despite them
I had to keep going
um so vegetarian out of Pride yeah I
couldn't let it go 20 years holy [__]
are these older brothers yeah and then
even when I stopped like when I was 18 I
thought I don't know if I want to do
this and they roasted the [__] out of me
because I suggested that I didn't want
to be a vegetarian anymore
suggested it and then you're like well
[__] it and then they they became one
not that vegan what and they start
telling me how I should be eaten
cheek of it yeah that's the shake of it
what did you what did you want what did
you aspire to be as a kid
uh different things
I'll get there one day when you're like
in elementary like eight eight years old
what did you go I'm gonna grow up and be
this pretty much what I ended up doing
just designing like I always knew I
wanted to do something in design or art
and then I did that I'm quite like a
tunnel vision person like that's the
only option so I just did that so what
did you design costumes how did you get
into costuming by lying honestly so I
was making like designing and making
stuff for myself and then I had like a
few shops that would sell it but it was
very like an isolated thing so I said I
want to go into costume it's like more
social there's more going on
so I just the first place I just sent
them like a bunch of stuff that I'd made
and they were like sure they gave me a
job
then I went to London and I was working
at a theater there just making costumes
doing whatever and one of the producers
girlfriends did like film stuff and she
said to me oh do you do costume for film
and I just said yes never done it
figured I'd work it out like how
different can it be and so she was like
oh cool my friend's a director and then
she got me a job on this film it was the
first one I ever did how different did
it end up being oh it was bad
because
I think the the difference with
stage is that like it's from a distance
so everything's just the silhouette and
the color the detail really mattered
yeah everything's in the detail
everything's in like us the first time I
saw them do like a close-up headshot and
I could see all the problems oh I was
like
were you the only one who saw the
problems or did the director also see
the problems and was like [__] this oh I
didn't ask
no problem nobody's voicing it why why
would I ask beautiful beautiful I
remember saying there was one thing
where the girl was like
it just didn't like fit properly like
you could tell around the thing and I
was like oh but you know I think it's
her character because she's kind of
crazy she's a single mom she's got all
these kids yeah it's Canon yeah it was a
creative choice and they were like
oh no I can see that because I was like
yes like all the other costumes look
like that yeah
that was like on purpose we've got a
hand raise over here oh yeah what do you
want baby you need to stop glassing all
over juicy details okay go ahead what
what's the juicy
what's the GCT type you just went
straight from oh I had a couple of shops
and then I went to London yeah
there's more meaning in between you went
there like a homeless Gypsy [__] with
a backpack on your back and you went to
London by yourself you didn't just do
this because people think oh what a
[__] rich girl daddy probably [__]
did that [__] for her no you were a
homeless exactly what I was thinking
glad you clarified thank you yeah I went
down to London I didn't have any I
didn't know anybody I didn't have jobs
or nothing like that why does it go to
London uh I felt like
I was running away a little bit one from
was a juicy detail yeah
I was very stuck in my head like quite
an anxious person very tightly wound and
I'd had like a bad year with that with
like mental health and like all that
kind of stuff and as I was coming out
the other end of it
it's very difficult to snap yourself out
of the headspace when you're with the
same surrounding
so it's easier to just completely remove
yourself put yourself somewhere
different and pretend that's fixed the
problem whereas if you stay in the same
environment and you're looking at the
same things you actually have to deal
with the issue whereas if you put
yourself somewhere else you can just
pretend but it's all better yeah so
that's why I went to London is that
better no I'll tell you the story cheese
take over by Joe I had a [__] mental
breakdown I didn't leave the house for a
goddamn year and I said you know what
this [__] is getting out of bed packing
my [__] and I'm going to London because
I need to do something with my life and
then if you [__] had a suitcase and
then you went in with no friends nothing
you went into a hostel and then you
started building yourself up found a job
now that's a [__] you don't have the
first stories
I had a mental breakdown ish I didn't
leave the house for three weeks not a
year how does a British girl cry
silently oh and with guilt
it's not oh no oh no oh no it's not like
yeah oh heavy it's just one single thing
yeah and then the queen behind you
rubbing your bag
rip rip and there's a [__] Queen's
guard just standing there just waiting
what was the moment that caused the
mental breakdown of you just crying and
like uh I think because I'm like
introverted if I'm not forced to be
social I don't so I think I was just too
alone too isolated too stuck in my head
and because I was like self-employed and
working a lot on my own
it gives you too much opportunity to
like lean into the anxiety whereas if
you're constantly forced to be with
people and you have other things coming
in it's kind of easier to get pulled out
of your own head yeah whereas if you're
just like sat in a studio like you're on
an island though yeah and then it's just
so easy just to lean into it so unless
you're like very self-aware and can see
yourself leaning in and pull yourself
out you just keep leaning in until it's
like too late and then what were your
thoughts then were you like [__] what am
I doing with my life or like what were
the things I felt like I was caving in
honestly got to a point really
remembered it and this was after I was
in London actually so I didn't really
live in one place so there was about
four or five years where technically I
was living in Liverpool but I was like
traveling for jobs and doing different
things so I was like moving around a lot
and I was like lying in the bed and I
should say like this is like dark yeah
that's the juicy stuff just for people
like so this isn't like a good mentality
to have this is like a bad like this you
know what you take this isn't advice but
you get to the good part by showing them
how I could go so so [__] illegal
coaching the come up
illegal coaching all right but for
people watching who care about me too
like a lot of people this isn't like a
thing that I talked about with people
but everybody cares so I was like lying
in bed right insomnia I couldn't sleep
and I had this thought that I was like
am I gonna have to live in this brain
for the next 65 years and that was like
so scary to me I was like I'm either
dealing with this or I'm opting out so
like everything after that was like
almost like religiously geared towards
moving myself out of that headspace and
then trying to get into a better one
literally just because in my mind I was
like 65 years of this it's brutal
that's just not happening that wasn't an
option so I kind of lined out the
options I had the last one being
professional help
which is where I think I made the
mistakes I do think actually you
probably should go straight to
professional help usually but it was
that was in the [__] category or that
but I just did research man I read books
went online did as much as I could like
compiled it but I think even to get to
that point you have to be some way out
of the darkness because I think if
you're caught up in it bad you're not
even thinking you're not going to apply
yourself in anything so I think I would
have already pulled myself a little bit
out of it before I got to that point
no oh okay
describe what dark was what does that
look like you warned everyone and you're
like be careful for the darkness and
then there's nothing dark to be worried
about I think that having the mentality
of fix it or opt out is not good advice
that's what my brain was what's up
yeah that was like my mentality oh I'm
trying not to say it because then it'll
get you out okay you guys didn't get
that you didn't get it either
okay that's dark Optometry
what's the opt-in but I think that like
I wasn't really in that position because
I think if you were really in that
position you wouldn't even be thinking
about fixing it the people that have
really got to that point like I don't
think I ever fully hit the rock box so
it was like okay I see well I mean you
know to give the credit to it though
even to acknowledge and to see that is
is a very dark place you know yeah it
was it was a weird thing because it was
like a logical decision it was like the
world is great and I've got wonderful
things happening but like this thing
where like I can't get out of my own
head that's the bit that needs to be
fixed yeah did you try jacking off all
the time honestly it helps because
that's like my first go-to if I feel sad
yeah and if I jack off that's your first
go-to it's a nice little reason if I go
oh [__] I'm still sad
sometimes
but if I jack off and everything's gone
oh I was just tripping yeah yeah I'll
just be an emotional yeah yeah okay yeah
until like the dopamine wears off and
you're like oh [__] this is awesome
sometimes you jack off after you bust
you go like start feeling really guilty
that happened didn't you do it again oh
I was tripping eight hours jacking off
in a room
I'm not talking to anyone
anybody you climbed you out of the
darkness you were it seems like you were
like thrown into a well and you're
looking up and you're like Bane and
you're like God what am I gonna do man
and then you climb up out of this well
and you [__] you're like the ginger
Grudge you just come out of that well
right and then you just a color TV
Grudge yeah
just [__] you just do this and you go
I'm going to London and then you just
[__]
rolly back yeah Vietnamese
[Laughter]
what was your biggest fear like what was
so bad about living here in first
another 65 years like what was like the
like the worst nightmare the
essay about really dark ideas of
thoughts or like constantly feeling like
you're doing things wrong or you're
hurting people you're doing bad things
it's like um
I would call it intrusive thinking and
just the conversation that you have with
yourself that bully inside your mind and
just constantly and not being able to
like shut it up that I think that
because you spent your whole life
trapped inside your brain right so if
that's not a nice place to be then it
doesn't matter how good everything else
is that's like yeah but I also felt like
I did it to myself because I hadn't
always been that way it was like a very
specific period of time where like I
think the lifestyle I had led me to that
yeah so I kind of also had that guilt of
like I did this to myself like I deserve
this yeah yeah yeah but then you pull
yourself out and now look at me yeah I'm
here with you guys I'm gonna hussy
[Applause]
um you know thank you Bart for
insightful like jacking off to avoid
depression type of things I think a lot
of fans will find that helpful it's a
good starting test yeah yeah you got to
test always it's like the doctor with
the [__] rubber triangle right go hit
the reflexes first make sure that's
working
you can move on to other things you can
still bust nuts but for going like this
and you're like whoa your leg's not
kicking yeah but now we gotta we're
gonna listen to somebody you know trying
to figure out what's going on
if you're not kicking we gotta bring out
the stethoscope
you still need some sort of like mental
brain power to get you to to the outcome
yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta make sure
some things are working right
but everything's fixable everything
that's what you learn what do you feel
like you're most talented at and what do
you think you need the most work at
um I think I'm got a good survival
Instinct like I'm very she's very
resourceful resourceful yeah
communication you know they're a good
communicator
hey hey man safe space
you don't want to make a bane again or
do you think in like all aspects of
communication or arms
I think that because for so long I was
hiding what was going on that like it's
very difficult now to like talk because
you get into a habit right so I think
I'm getting better
what I do now though which I think
annoys him is that if I'm annoyed by
something I'll say like I'll tell him
like I'm annoyed but I don't know why
yet so you have to wait the whole day
until I work out why I'm annoyed and
then I'll tell you that's great but
until process what you said much later
too
when you don't answer her till like two
three days later I'm annoyed okay
are you ready to oh you're gonna tell me
now okay so the delay kind of works
delayed receptor yeah we're both delayed
delayed processing this is why it works
we were staying at bat and GEOS one time
and like I was so annoyed with him right
do you remember yeah remember you're
crying I was crying you know what he did
right I'm pretty stupid now what
happened do you remember I was saying it
was in jail and I hadn't been sleeping
like my I was just like we were
traveling a lot I was just tired right
so then one day I'm like I finally get
to sleep right so I'm sleeping in the
morning and we had made this plan that
we were gonna film in the morning right
so he's just sticking to the plan but
I'm asleep finally after like a while
and I didn't know that she didn't have
good sleep so I was like knocked out and
then I just feel like the whole bed
shape this man jumps up opens the
curtains turns on all the lights right
and starts filming
your face dude I feel it like you know
that feeling of just like I can't
believe this is happening right now yeah
but he's thinking in his mind like this
was the plan this is what we were gonna
do we were gonna wake up and film yeah
so he's sticking to the plan
so it was really hard for me to like
okay how do I word why this annoyed me
because I know that I'm the one who's
changed the situation right yeah and I
haven't communicated to him that I so
what I'm annoyed at is that he didn't
look macro at the whole situation right
so then he's gone downstairs I'm in bed
I'm pissed right so I texted
and I was like I don't want to talk
about this now but I'm really angry at
you
yeah
and then we were like went through the
whole day just the whole day normal hung
out with them I think we went to dinner
and he didn't even know why you're mad
it's a stalemate in your head a little
bit what did you think oh no we talked
about it Midway through oh no we did we
went into the car park well but before
that so me trying to be considerate I
made her even more mad because she was
like I didn't [__] sleep right and
I'm all like oh she probably doesn't
want to she wants like to take a nap or
some [__] right so I was like so then I
just like left her and then I worked out
with Barton Geo and I was just like yeah
she's tired
man you know and then she was mad
because she wanted to come work out too
but she did it so she got left and then
I was like I didn't know yeah and then
what I [__] up is I should have
checked in and been like and and then
just asked and I I wasn't a good
communicator because then I just made up
the decision that she needs more rest
and I'ma leave her alone and that was
like neglect rather than like because
you just diagnosed it and I just [__]
said let me let me just solve it and I'm
gonna go work out with bar and leave him
man yeah so we went to a car park
because we were driving and he was like
we can't finish the day unless you tell
me what's wrong so then we went to a
college park and just talked like an
hour about how he woke me up
and I do wake her up a lot
yeah but it took me like a whole day
because I couldn't work out why I was
annoyed because technically he had done
the thing that we'd agreed upon so he
was technically in the right right yeah
but then not but
he didn't read the rules yeah you didn't
read the room yeah yeah yeah but I think
that doesn't work right either we don't
fight much because you look at all those
pieces before you lash out on me yeah I
mean you did get mad at me but then I
didn't feel like you were attacking me I
was like oh I [__] up but what did I
do and then yeah we did argue because
we're like defending each position but
then it always ends and I think it is
the first relationship where it ends
with like a resolve yeah because it's
always been every fight that I've had in
the past was like no you need to
understand me and then why you're wrong
and it was that kind of you just glaze
over and there's no resolution there is
it because it usually comes in the form
of an accusation or attack that already
Cuts so then I'm already at this
position of no I didn't do anything
wrong you're just being crazy I'm gonna
tell you why you're wrong yeah but then
the approached it was like I was like oh
I [__] up but I have a little pride
and we're gonna fight this out and then
later I was like okay the fact that she
was able to be like
I know we were you're sticking to the
plan but then I wanted this to be done
and you didn't do that and then the way
she laid it out to me I was like oh damn
no one's ever like did A to Z for me
like that and that makes a lot of sense
and so you are a good communicator in
that sense but it takes me a minute
like so it took like that was like early
morning and I think it was like late
afternoon before you just sort it all
out in the car
packed was it in the castle
he's trying to tell you how to say it I
know oh is that what's happening all
right you're a bad Communicator it's
just the timeliness of the communication
makes makes the most I'm usually the one
that pulls you into reality and talk to
talk about whatever I get caught in my
head a lot yeah yeah I mean the fact
that you started off by even saying
straight up that you were angry is nice
yeah yeah like some people don't even do
that most people they're just angry at
you already and then they're already
dishing it out versus telling you like
hey I'm angry yeah and then but there's
some time yeah yeah but it's like cool I
know your feelings but you're not like
physically or like being throwing that
you're not taking it out yeah you're not
taking it out on them
no you're not punishing for it yeah yeah
a little bit I'm like if I'm gonna be
mad you're in this with me
what's wrong nothing nothing no nothing
you you should know already yeah I'm
fine the real question is was there
makeup sex in the compact
s in a few rooms in your old house nice
me and Nick did in your bedroom
in separate beds
dude you got you guys are supposed to
talk about her oh no it's fine okay uh
uh bring it back to her um if you could
be any kind of Asian what would you be
oh that's a great question oh Japanese
probably really yeah don't make it about
him yeah why because she already share
some of my DNA yeah I'm probably like 40
job but there's only gonna be like a few
Generations left
it's not like you're sending your kids
there anyway so I mean we could I guess
the profit is cheap
okay if you had a hall pass for any male
celebrity who would it be
cool you can [__] them I
um for any male celebrity we can't take
a shower after because I need to have
some of that residuals
silly and silly and Murphy you know the
peaky blinders guys that's Anthony's too
that's a great choice
why did so many guys agree that's a
great show I thought you don't like
white guys that's just what I tell you
okay fine
yo what's what what's one of your I want
to know what's your fashion goal like do
you have any more things you want to do
in fashion that you haven't yet
I don't know because I've been thinking
about this a lot right because
I don't know if this is gonna be like
get me in trouble
if we do have kids I don't know if
that's the industry I want to be in when
I'm a mom really why I think the way I
was doing it anyway the way I was
working it's long hours you travel a lot
you're going out a lot it's like a lot
of socializing I don't know if that's
the family structure I would want and
that's not like to criticize other
people that do it in that way just how
like I grew up and so I started thinking
like if we're planning on doing that at
some point do I want to keep pushing
down that path and then have to cut it
short or do I start something new that I
could do whilst also having kids like
work at Gymboree
apparently that's your choice though
could you be Liverpool or something
Liverpool be good actually or June B
Wales
I love whales but there's not that many
people there yeah freak whales yeah
thank you